بنواجه تحديات وصعوبات كبيره في اخراج
المصابين والشهداء من تحت الانقاض لا سما
انه نقص المعدات نحن نعتمد بشكل كامل
على الكوادر البشريه وعلى قوه السواعد
هناك شح كبير في المعدات احنا بنحاول قد
ما نقدر في سواعدنا وبمعدات القليله
المتوفره انه نخرج المصابين الشهداء من
تحت الانقاض في الايام السابقه تم استهداف
طواقمنا بشكل مباشر في غزه وفي رفح وادى
ذلك الى استشهاد البعض من زملائنا واصابه
البعض وفي منهم يعني خطير في المستشفيات
لحتى لا يتلقون العلاج بسبب نقص الوقود
تكاد مركباتنا الى وقف العمل ولا تستطيع
العمل بعد ذلك ونحن نحتاج الى كميات وقود
لتشغيل هذه المركبات والاليات
بشوف مناظر يعني كثير فظيعه للاسف الشديد
لكن ما كنتش اتخيل في يوم من الايام انه
يكونوا اهلي مثل يعني هذه المناظر اللي
انا بشيلها كانت صدمه كبيره وطبعا اول ما
شفت البيت مهدوم تحت
القصف انهرت على الارض ومن بعديه انا ما
بتذكر
شي
ه